I am super excited I love this time of
year I've always said that
if I work in the games industry and I'm
not excited about E3 I know it's
technically not cold E3 this year but
same thing that I should leave and give
my place up to somebody else that I
don't deserve it
um
so today I started work a little bit
early
because I expect this to be like more
like two hours so I'm taking my lunch
break
to watch it maybe I'm not sure how long
I said it was I've not seen any leaks or
anything spoiled for me at all I haven't
even seen any rumors absolutely nothing
stuff I'm looking forward to I mean I
know there's a separate Xbox conference
but like leading into this I'm really
excited about fable
and I would love to see some different
colors for the Xbox series X rather than
just the black but I don't know if
they'd announce that through something
like this would like to see more
Dragon's Dogma
while and wake
um
and I wonder if we'll see more of Judas
that seems like a thing we might get at
the Achilles which is um Ken Levine's
game uh otherwise
oh I know I've seen Mortal Kombat that
might be the big opener because that
looks goddamn awesome the trailer looked
incredible would love to see more
gameplay
Final Fantasy 7 News would be great
would love that Elder and DLC yeah
um
there's one other thing that I had in
mind that I'm now forgetting about
oh Fort Solace I'd like to see more from
Fallout Solace too
um which is coming out the end of this
year
because I think Jeff had that last time
I know that's something to do with
fortnite here as well but I'm not a big
fortnite person so
cyberpunk DLC uh I imagine that actually
probably will be here
so yeah 10 seconds everybody well five
four three two
one
I'm excited let's do it
appreciate the heads up thanks Jeff
means a lot
also yeah I'm still very sick so excuse
my voice and how often I have to clear
my throat I may have to mute the mic
occasionally to cough
I got invited but I didn't go in person
so I could be here with all of you chat
I hope you appreciate that
foreign
welcome to summer game fast thanks Chef
happy to be here
we in person and today we've got a look
at what's next in video games for you
how's it going in person like with the
people in the room that's cool
also how's the audience
maybe make Jeff a little louder
volume slow okay
he is quieter than I expected
when I started summer game Fest back in
I never imagined it would grow into this
the video game industry has come
together to show you what's next this is
a cross industry showcase meaning no
matter where you play games I hope
you'll discover a new game to put on
your wish list exciting exciting
exciting a video game events has
certainly changed over the past few
years but one thing hasn't there are a
lot of great games in development and
our singular goal today is to get you
excited about the future in just a few
minutes we'll see the first extended
gameplay
does it need to be even louder it is
only one person saying that do you all
agree with them what's the consensus
[Applause]
the reveal of four nights next season
and yes we do have a very special Grand
Finale tiny bit there we go that you're
not gonna want to miss
all say right okay
but let's get right to the games and
gameplay
which makes it that much more exciting
here we go
cursed
principles surely not
they didn't land
Prince of Persia progressed with us
The Immortals to rescue him and save the
Empire it's not what I would if it is
not what I would expect it to look like
what then again oh my god really what a
weird
okay that actually looks pretty sick
put on the other I guess they have to
make sure that princess pejo is like
different to Assassin's Creed the combat
looks duh
I'm not a fan of how fortnite is
and it's sort of spite of us
which is interesting oh oh oh we got
Ahri Vibes in here
damn if if
I'm happy to see Ubisoft making a game
like this anyway I love the like Child
of Light hope is the only thing that
keeps us fighting era Valiant Hearts
it's sort of like that
and save the kingdom
no way wow
that's cool
that that looks actually very good
[Applause]
there's a little surprise Prince of
Persia the Lost Crown damn I had no idea
24 a brand new action adventure
platformer in the iconic series with
deep combat some huge boss fights and of
course incredible platforming puzzles
and animation bringing any modern take
on the legendary friends you'll be able
to see more at Ubisoft forward streaming
on Monday as part of Summer game Fest
all right let's move along to another
franchise just celebrated 30 years
that's right it's time for Mortal Kombat
one
this game looks incredible
it has been four years since MK 11 and
ever since Ed Boone the team at
netherrealm have been hard at work on
the most ambitious MK yet that reboots
the series into a New Era timeline yeah
I was pretty confused about the choices
one but everyone has been asking what
does it look like who's on the roster
how do the new Cameo Fighters work well
now it is time for combat no spoilers
but this video is literally insane here
is an extended First Look At The Story
gameplay and yes of course the
fatalities of Mortal Kombat well we can
get demonetized ladies and gentlemen
come on
[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down the facial animations
look really good too damn
this looks so good though
worthy of joining us
come there are other Champions I must
gather
what do you want said toe it's my family
blade cento's mine look at all this
story all right okay
thank you
oh my God
oh I love it
Jesus
that wasn't even the finisher
fatality brother
enough
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth rail
god of fire
the voice acting is very good too
oh my God this looks so [__] cool
inexperienced whatever experience I lack
I make up for in heart
beautiful depth to the backgrounds as
well
it looks so good
if you're disease
oh these are different skins are in the
um reveal as well
I think they are
sorry I forgot to talk just my mind
she's very into this
sometimes I forget that I'm streaming
when I watch them
insane dude
[Music]
oh God
it's so creative oh
oh don't like those ones Jesus
oh my God
that looks
very very very good
wow what a bag of
amazing
I mean that was pretty good right
now I'm sure you have many questions
about what we just saw and to tell you
more I am so honored to welcome to
summer game Fest one of our industry's
greatest creators a man who has been
loyal to the same franchise and fan base
for more than three decades it's crazy
welcoming to summer game Fest the
creator of Mortal Kombat Ed boo
[Applause]
[Music]
I've met Ed a couple of times and he is
lovely congratulations
[Music]
they love you all right well Ed uh first
of all thank you for that incredible uh
World premiere we got to see all the
games it does look MK very good everyone
just wants to know more about this
because first of all this is in a it's
emblem to one so tell us about this is
it a new timeline yeah yeah um I don't
know how many people have seen the the
ending of Mortal Kombat 11 Liu Kang
basically was kind of graduated into
like you know a fire got right and he's
he created a brand new universe and this
universe this is why we're calling it
Mortal Kombat one is because this is the
beginning of a new timeline a number of
these characters you've seen before but
they're told in a completely different
story that's cool so Sub-Zero and
Scorpion are brothers now and there's
there's all these things that were
rivalries before are now allies and so
mixing the whole thing up so we're just
kind of rebooting and that's what the
one is for well it looks incredible
everything we saw there was you know in
game gameplay the cinematics look
incredible I know the team has been
working for four years on this but the
thing we gotta talk about are these
cameos because we saw some pretty
amazing stuff there now tell us how does
that work you obviously you have your
sort of your main you know character
that you'll pick and then I know you
also have a separate kind of Cameo menu
so you pick sort of a pair when you
start the game whoa the menu looks so
sick dude I didn't expect that what a
great menu
after you do that there's a second
roster of characters which are a whole
new uh completely different Fighters
that are the Cameo Fighters and these
Fighters actually they will join the
fight but the blank squares there yes so
it's kind of like imagine yourself with
sub-zero but you have some of Jack's
moves and you can call him out you can
do it multiple times as you saw in the
gameplay you know yeah
you can basically combine these two
characters all the characters can be
combined with all the Cameo Fighters and
that's where you see that's where the
players kind of imagination so cinematic
can actually customize it for what they
like seeing you know the best team-ups
maybe I should how does that work
gameplay you have your main you have
your cameo if you sum of them is it time
base like how often do they come in it's
not a text thing right yeah and you're
you're basically summoning them it's
just one button basically summoning but
they have a variety so you can go you
know push that button with towards and
it'll do a different move push it with
down it'll do a different move and so
the combination oh I see so you can
bring them in a combo exactly exactly
and and so I love the environment
against the depth we've done such a good
job of making that you can't obviously
fire them
indefinitely but um you call you can
call them pretty much whenever you want
and they have you know like in the
middle of a combo they'll have a lot of
um you know basically a whole arsenal of
their moves so Sony Utah come out there
sometimes you'll see them appear twice
in there to me so time base they come
out and then obviously as you go through
you revealed some of them there but is
it a different set of characters that'll
be in the cameos are there some repeats
from the main roster how will that work
yeah yeah some of the characters are
going to be available as cameos as well
as the main roster fighter so you can
play Sub-Zero I like that he's alive
it means they caught really good but a
lot of our our Cameo Fighters are kind
of like nods back to our first game so
you'll notice Sonia and Kano and Jack I
like theater of doing live interviews so
that and so there's there's a lot of
like really surprised with I think you
you guys saw Goro yes
so there's a lot of like kind of really
digging into the old Mortal Kombat games
as far as getting you know um we really
love the novelty of it we really want
the Cameo characters to feel uh you know
kind of Nod to the old games
well speaking of uh 90 of the old games
let's talk you confirmed I think or at
least knowing that Jean-Claude Van Damme
is actually going to be in this game as
Johnny Cage right is that true yeah
that was people don't know the story I
mean Bloodsport was such an inspiration
for Mortal Kombat so he finally is now
yeah part of it it's a huge first that's
cool
the first Mortal Kombat game we
originally wanted to be Van Damme the
video game and that and that never
really worked out so I I can't tell you
how many times over the last 30 years
we've tried to get him uh you know we
are this close four or five times that's
so cool and uh so finally we got him and
he's doing the voices too so you're
gonna hear John Claude his voice doing
Johnny Cage lines and stuff like that
we're really excited about it wow well I
know the team has been working so hard
in Chicago to build this through covid
and it's coming out in September so
enough to wait long right that's right
with this this has been a very difficult
uh secret to keep over the last over the
last four years and so uh but we're
we could not be more excited in terms of
uh getting players hands on it um and
you know throughout the summer we're
going to be showing a lot more content a
lot more characters a lot more Cameo it
looks phenomenal I love it the Pila
fighting game franchise directions
what they doing uh Ed Boone thank you so
much first look at Laurel College like
the direction of Mortal Kombat and
Street Fighter they all look like very
very good next up it's been a fun couple
weeks for Action RPG fans with the
release of Diablo 4 which is truly
fantastic another big and anticipated
arpg is Path of Exile 2 from grinding
gear games who have Faithfully been
updating and patching the original Poe
since its release in 2013. we haven't
seen anything on the sequel in over two
years but that changes right now there
are changes today
sure from Path of Exile to tweet a
sequel that pushes the engine and
gameplay to a new level
[Applause]
where are the guards
hey you what's going on
unfortunate that these are both like
probably gonna come out in the same year
though
oh that was nice
love that ice AOE
whoa
[__] cool reveal as well Diablo 4
doesn't do that
but yeah it'd be nice if they come out
space apart you know
okay so they'll have their own
conference in July 28th I guess that
looked
Mark the release of Street Fighter six a
game we featured last year at summer
game Fest well the team at Capcom has an
important update to share with you right
now
foreign
[Music]
YouTube
is is it EXO primal
Cross Street Fighter
what the [__] bro they must be
right are they
yeah okay okay
so maybe you get Robo characters in both
like a skin in Street Fighter and the
playable that's actually really smart
I'm guessing it's a really good idea
fighter facing off against a dinosaur
probably wasn't on your bingo card for
today's show it wasn't none it's sick
though Primal collab will launch in the
fall with the game coming out on July
14th but guess what guys that's cool
actually not
collaboration on the show today I
haven't checked this out
there's nothing more powerful than
imagination Nick Cage dead by daylight
I did that really fast huh transforming
everything you may think you know
yeah
I'm like mad proud of how quick that was
but we've already seen that are we
getting gameplay
we already do that's right Nicholas Cage
is coming to dead by daylight in July I
mean I don't know how these things
happen but but we already knew that I
figured the easiest way to find out is
probably to go right to the source
[Applause]
bold creative choices have earned him an
Academy Award and a few memes on the
internet across four Decades of
incredible films please
summer game fast Nicholas Cage
oh my God what the hell
[Applause]
oh my God that's so nice oh wow yeah
thank you I'm so happy to be invited to
your very very cool Club everybody
[Applause]
a crazy unexpected what's going on how
did this why he didn't like oh maybe we
didn't do it maybe he'll be in a day
but dead by daylight I mean how does
this happen well it's it's a museum of
horror right and when I make movies one
of my favorite genres is horror and in
this and and in that genre there's a
character a murderous ghost named sadiko
who I think is amazing she made an
appearance I guess we'll find out if
he's a villain or a hero because I
actually wasn't clear on that point one
of the survivors in this game you know
it really is this Museum of horror
Michael Myers you said all these
different it's pretty cool together
um and you do you you play yourself or
who do you play so I play this uh
heightened exaggerated version of a film
actor named Nick Cage
and he's uh he's going to a location
thinking he's making a movie and instead
he wakes up in the fog that's cute and
in the fog he's surrounded by crows and
serial killers and it's rather amusing
and there's something about it that I
think as a Survivor is like a bonding
experience it's a bit like hide and go
seek you have your three other teammates
who are survivors with you and it's
teamwork you're working together to pull
through and I like it it's like he's
just he's just discovering what that my
daylight is and he's like it's this
crazy game friends and you're fully
Infamous I know we heard your voice in
there so you recorded lines for it and
everything see I want you to know when
you're playing the Nick Cage Survivor I
even have when you're choosing your
skins I even say always remember to
dress to match your talent I want you to
know that you're with me that we're one
that were fused and so it was important
to me that everything I do everything I
see is about it though I feel like the
most minimal
all right
seems super genuinely excited that's
really cool I mean this is so fun this
game as you said is such an awesome kind
of you know collaboration with so many
different characters for you I mean how
did you find out about dead by daylight
do you know much about the video game
somebody very important in my family is
a dead by daylight Enthusiast and and
that really put the uh hook in pun
intended nice
uh see dead by daylight to me was an
opportunity to Branch out a lot of
people would find anything for the money
but he seems that's what I mean like a
lot of I'm always the active Adventures
so this to me was like wow I can I make
it I can make tend to actually think
video games are kind of white and Branch
out and go on this dead by daylight
Adventure I didn't say it took me
nothing but a split second to say yes
and speaking about split seconds what's
so cool excuse me what I noticed
what I noticed was that every move you
make when you're doing this when you're
in the gaming space it's it's time down
to the Split Second it's an it's a very
immersive experience when you're acting
out in this space because every move
every grunt every saw you make has to be
timed perfectly with the gamers move so
that was something that I learned from
this and I'm always looking to learn
something well we love having you in the
video game where we want to see Nick
Cage in more games thanks guys
Nicholas Cage great to see you I do
think it's a really good idea
now for all of you who want to play Nick
Cage in dead by daylight Jeff Kelly just
kicked Nick Cage up to stage
console but PC players can try it
earlier by downloading the player test
build on July 5th and here's an
exclusive first look at Nicholas Cage
let's do it
his face
something about it is just hilarious
like especially because we've just seen
him talk and now it's just completely
like expression
incredible work incredible work dead by
daylight team
[Music]
let's even show what this is did I miss
it while I was coughing
[Music]
The Witch Hunt maybe we had heard of
that before
I think we might have oh maybe I'm
thinking which fire yeah
so then no we haven't seen before
I feel like it's interesting how many oh
it is which fire okay so yeah
um oh rad
um we're seeing like quite a few games
that look like that completely
so oh sorry we're in an ad segment now
this is these ads not reveals I think
ps52 is safe
the uh episode of playlist listening is
going up tomorrow by the way everybody
is all about
the Apple Vision Pro since I couldn't
upload my actual video because Apple
demonetized it is on patreon though my
reaction to that let's go
[Music]
is this whole show just an ad no
um
I mean trailers are all marketing but no
they're not
Jeff's intent is not just to make you
buy stuff
foreign
I think his intent was to celebrate
gaming I think what Jeff's done for the
industry is pretty phenomenal whoa
whoa
you what mate
we have no choice 40 OLED 49 my current
model is 49 inches
[Music]
can we go back to the monitor
that's sick
all right
let's just run into turning back after
this you sure
[Music]
this
there's such a specific way of like
video game voice acting that I only
learned recently which is like
female protagonists are always very
breathy
you sure
so I'm turning back after this are you
sure like it's just really breathy
uh sorry about the pitch ads if you want
to suck
you can't so I should to get rid of the
ads and we donate uh some money in the
chair
I love the first game by the way
the first um actually I love everything
that studio does I'm a really big fan of
them in general
Kronos is still like your favorite video
game remna is in the same world as
Kronos
[Applause]
um
Remnant rules if you haven't played it I
made the made everyone play at a fun
house
to come including a first look at the
gameplay of Alan Wake two the world
premiere of the new season Call of Duty
C4 and maybe a few more surprises for
you well maybe it's a more surprises
this is the hashtag gaming on tickets
sorry to react to the news we want to
welcome everyone co-streaming the show
live on Tick Tock twitch YouTube and
other platforms that's me hi those of
you on Twitter which we also have a
special Warframe twitch drop a free
steinax Warframe for watching more than
30 minutes of the show now always that
the Wolfram Partnerships that's good
he's going to be getting paid legendary
gaming Hero set to return later this
year in a brand new game built from the
ground up in a style that I think is
going to get this fan base and long time
fans of video games very excited hey
look at Steve
with a classic feel
what
oh my God a Sonic announcement I'm
actually excited for
[Music]
those first levels are like such a
staple of my childhood because I used to
play them at school on a browser
I don't know how somebody got them
browser base
but I do it anytime we had Computing
class
oh my God I love it I'm so here for this
foreign
[Music]
usually my approach to Sonic games is
like yeah it looks pretty cool I love
Sonic as a franchise in like a
a way that I find it very fun
this though
actually stoked dude
[Music]
I have so much nostalgia
oh my God he's dead
that rules
that rules love it
[Applause]
[Music]
big fan huge fan huge fan
[Applause]
I'm a classic Sonic that's bound to
appeal to new and Legacy oh my God I'm
so stoked this past April Hong Kong I
did not expect my most hyped
announcement of the show so far to be
still a character just fantasy RPG we
don't just have a new how do you feel
about Frontiers um I didn't finish it
awaiting the game's release on
Playstation but in the end I
I just didn't like the open world very
much
has a few more things to do don't you
get bored running across the map every
day see what I mean by breathy every day
mission one accomplished where's our
next stop I can't wait
[Music]
a day ahead of us see breathy
I saw those physics
Jeff
great
I get warmed up
first
I don't know what this is though
need a hand my pleasure Hi-Fi Rush too
that was a joke
a good one though it's continuously
getting more fitting
huh never mind I miscalculated
can you let me have some fun this time
[Music]
codename PlayStation five that's not no
it's
just thematic
okay style rail okay
unfamiliar looks pretty cool right
inspired by the story of Pinocchio Liza
p is a soulsborne like game very excited
about his appeal is which is coming to
Game Pass PlayStation and PC this year
well if you're wondering exactly when we
have news to share with you on its
release with this brand new trailer
awesome I this game looks so sick
oh
stop it
I need your help
that was cool dude
[Music]
this is one of those ones that I feel
like I gotta play
[Music]
getting the style of combat down is hard
they've clearly nailed the art and it's
Unique it looks like their own thing
[Music]
uh shut up feminist
you're ruining video games
[Music]
so sick
the goddamn environments
[Music]
so pretty
like how does it feel to play
that's awesome
[Music]
nice very good editing man great job
I just want to touch it I want to touch
the video game
with my hands
damn August September
again
[Applause]
[Music]
oh oh I will thank you that's right a
demo is now available across PlayStation
that's great Xbox and PC thank you I
appreciate you on September 19th you
know what drives me nuts about the way
reveal of a visually stunning new game
basically a lot of people do conference
reactions there's a lot of them are just
angry people like this
of all time this is one of those games
that I feel lucky we get to reveal for
the first time here at Summer game Fest
and I think you'll be pretty hyped once
you see the gameplay all built in on
real engine five here we go
mostly wintry
no not awesome entry Wasteland
surely not
nope
nope it's not an Austin game and it is
not
Wasteland oh my God is it Dragon Ball
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a visually stunning
I mean it looks cool I don't know about
visually stunning Jeff
definitely looks cool this is
looks super unique
[Music]
but it's not actually Dragon Ball it's
just Dragon Ball Aesthetics huh
it's like a
Dragon Ball the Lance is very good
no I can't get dragonfall the lands out
of my head and I forgot what I was gonna
say so
Mad Max thank you that's what I was
going to say Mad Max we come in unlikely
hero an adventure where you don't need
to be human to save Humanity uh that's
coming from Bandai Namco and we're
excited to see more of it soon
independent games are such an important
part of this is very interesting and one
thing that's very important to us at
summer game Fest is supporting those
creators as well after the live show
stay tuned for Day of the devs from
im8bit and double fine with some
incredible indie game reveals now one of
the biggest individuals
Annapurna interactive um later this
month as part of Summer game Fest
they'll be revealing a number of
ambitious new projects let's see how
many you can figure out in this little
tease
cool
[Music]
out of Waltz
uh uh [__] I want to pause it um that's
uh black uh [__] the Speed Run game I
hope it's called
[Music]
neon neon neon white
oh uh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we will be streaming that one ladies and
gentlemen
Anna Turner only makes
we're stepping into the world of throne
and Liberty wait does that mean neon
white
from ncsoft and Amazon games with an
always changing or just updates massive
skills pvpve and the ability to
transform into creatures to battle
across land sea and air here's a look at
Throne of Liberty
Amazon games huh
you sure it's not gonna be canceled
ancient evil searches for these lost
fragments
destroying anything in their path
you must find them
harness their power
that was cool
put down this threat once and for all
this is a very cinematic trailer for
it's a PVP
pvpve right I imagine this game doesn't
look like this
hard to say
more of that breathy female voice that's
what I'm saying
[Music]
oh sorry I was shaking my leg you guys
are probably seeing that
oh
[Music]
this one
again I don't imagine most gameplay
actually looks like that trailer looks
like
I feel like they are dramatically
different based on what time the game it
is
looks great I also want to say hello to
everybody watching on Steam right now
I'm sorry we don't have any free steam
decks for you right now but on June 19th
steam nextfest does return giving fans a
chance to try out Steve we're gonna have
some new in developments one of them for
anyone who doesn't know that's Steve
Salo who um
here's a new look
that's a really good way
to do
player reactions
party animals looked awesome um because
they're genuine they didn't do the
Ubisoft
hey uh yeah I'm just gonna go to the um
I'm just gonna head to base camp you
want to come with me yeah I'll be right
there
straight
no
a lot of cool stuff will make his way to
Dying Light to stay human get ready for
darker more dangerous nights and roaming
volatiles complete with improved parkour
rolling out it was funny the overlap
between aesthetically stray and Dying
Light is like I have never seen before
impressive
once soon you will be the deadliest
Summers to date
oh okay these are ads again
not oh
[Music]
it's okay
oh yeah I had a ton of fun playing this
with beta I'm gonna be playing it on
launch with um
thank you
I wish they would differentiate between
when we're seeing the actual show and
when we're seeing
like Jeff
Jeff should be saying and now what from
responses or something right also while
we're watching these ads
that's one thing about the twitch
um updated content guidelines that
rolled out that they woke back
that is worth noting
is that would prevent summer game Fest
it would prevent the accessibility
summer game Fest isn't that great by the
way crash getting rid of some games
and engine
neocortex's right hand guy in Season one
now it's time to change the topic and
descent is so good joining me is a guy
who was last on stage at the game awards
2021 to announce Alan Wake 2.
let's go
see you looking Dapper as always thank
you thank you well we are so excited
because when you announced uh Alan Wake
Up the game where Alan Wake two at the
game it looks really good 23. we are in
and we are so excited about the Sam I
know it's been a long time
for you 13 years since the first Alan
Wake so tell us a bit about what can we
expect in the sequel it's been quite a
journey yet
um
Alan Wake 2 is remedy's first survival
horror game we have two playable
characters it's a 50 50 split between
them they are on their own separate
terrifying Journeys through two
different worlds and yet it's all
connected and the player gets to switch
between them at given points in the in
the story as they choose
yeah we saw obviously at the PlayStation
event you revealed uh Saga the the
second character uh tell us a bit about
her she's in bright Falls and she's sort
of living a narrative that Alan has
written is that right well uh I love
like good questions especially with all
the control stuff like it was kind of
implied we have Alan Wake Up director of
course trying to escape
dark place yeah and then we have Saga
our new hero FBI agent uh coming to the
Pacific Northwest small town of Brighton
people [__] love the Pacific with her
partner
ah so how and they're somehow linked in
some way right uh they are coming to
investigate yes a series of ritualistic
murders okay and and very quickly the
investigation turns into a nightmare
when they discover pages of a Horror
Story uh maybe written by a certain
missing writer uh initials AAW and and
this Horror Story starts to come true
around them interesting so obviously
it's you know Alan is still going to win
it playable in the game you're going to
experience his journey but uh Saga this
is her new character and there is that
sort of Link tell us a bit about you
said split 50 50 do they have separate
missions how because I think you can you
can play them in sort of different
sequences or orders if you want that's
cool yeah we we go into the experience
I'm actually getting to see the game and
and on Saturdays it's uh talk about it
but it's also a standalone experience we
are not expecting everybody to do
homework okay three games that I booked
in to see on Saturday yeah all three
this can be enjoyed uh so excited Saga
doesn't know anything about something
more about the supernatural uh in this
world she will be going in very quickly
if she has to learn to survive and with
that all the players uh will be on on
that Journey with with her and and uh
then we open up the experience so that
you can hope to play Alan Wake in the
dark place as he's trying to find his
way out and you can keep on playing as
Saga in the Pacific Northwest as the
investigation goes on so you're free to
switch to story time there are a lot of
connection points yes in many surprising
ways but there is no right way to play
through this you can choose you can go
on as as Alan all the way close to the
end or a saga or you can keep hopping
between these two uh sorry well you're
always so good at kind of telling
challenging interesting narratives in
unique ways I mean remedy's always been
known for that new especially so we
can't wait to see how these stories the
thing I don't like about Alan Wake today
though is Alan I know you brought with
you some some gameplay he's very whining
Adventure we're just going to see a raw
segment of the game right yeah raw
gameplay for the first time ever this is
early on from The Experience his wife
who is trying to save
I think having Alan be tortured so tell
us what an FBI agent investigating makes
so much more sense
of Darkness have uh brought the murder
victim in this case Back to Life as a
model like as a character and uh Saga is
outside Pride Falls at qualton Lake
trying to find him and stop him
okay with that let's take a look at Raw
unedited gameplay from Alan Wake too
thank you excited
so do we still have the flashlight
combat and Linda
I also wonder how like different it was
for them to develop with obviously um a
much more
survival horror camera
the original Alan Wake
did not look like this
it's the first remedy game I think where
you haven't always been able to see the
whole character sounds like somebody's
home
it looks scarier
another breathy voice actress I guess
I'll listen out for it
somebody's home
weird there's a light on that's me not a
just in case it wasn't close
oh I'm gonna be [__] terrified
foreign
Pacific Northwest baby
well still technically a deer oh okay
wait sorry
I so you the light she was flashing the
torch on him regardless and shooting huh
animation's really good oh my God I'm
gonna be so scared
I'm gonna have to stream the whole thing
that's the strategy for playing scary
games is that I I film a couple what I
streamed because then I could talk to
people I'd look at chat occasionally you
guys really help me through it
oh that's creepy
this animation was so good and it's
something I love about a game like this
they usually have the zombies
dude look like a [__] serial killer
oh still very remedy
that that uh that respectfully that was
some remedy-ass [__]
she has breathy guys
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
killer left a message
it's for us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something I'm forgetting
dude this looks so scary
oh they got multiple ops Oh no
also also nice to see unedited gameplay
a long time coming but Alan Wake 2 looks
incredible thank you to Sam and remedy
for that person let's go now let's get a
first look at the co-op campaign of
Warhammer Space Marine 2 from saber and
focus
don't mind if I do to be honest
Splinter Fleet they engaged us on two
planets avarax and kadaku this game
looks very good
I have my reservations about your
reinstatement actually I would say it
looks so good that I doubt him
like the combat looks so good with so
many enemies on screen like this
that I doubt this game functions I'm
like there's no way it's gonna have
three of my traps everywhere
the game looked too good
right this Abomination how about those
particles
it looks unreal
like
I would like to see it
open the gates Gears of Warhammer is
fair but to be fair spooky
years of war was inspired by Warhammer
excuse the world took inspiration for
more money
it looks
so good
[Applause]
we back to ads now
oh oh
um
two crowns
do you have two crowds
the game that I play with Steve
[Music]
probably not
very Fable three
yes your grace
oh maybe we've seen that before too
actually that looks sick
add to wish list
now it is time for another Global game
announcement and this one comes from the
minds of saber interactive Focus
entertainment and yes horror Master John
Carpenter It's a Brand New World a brand
new story and looks like a heck of a lot
of fun okay let's go
I'm getting a lot of horror lately I
really feel like uh Capcom
single-handedly did that you gotta be
ready
just absolutely kill it
and all the other Publishers are like
Ruby
[Music]
on my mark
five four three left the gun type movie
this one's a horror game
celebrity found a horror game I wouldn't
have thought so oh FPS
don't love that
I mean it looks very low for Daddy
[Music]
obviously with significantly better
graphics and vehicles which is cool
I don't like this trailer though
because I also feel like the music
doesn't really suit the vibe
[Music]
me
just not really my vibe more unexpected
collaboration Sean Carpenter and Savor
with toxic Commando that looks uh tons
of fun you guys need to stand out a bit
more all right well this August brings
the long-awaited full 1.0 release of
Baldur's Gate three and today a new
member is joining the cast we're about
to see the reveal of Lord Ember gortash
the commander of a mechanical Army of
Steel Watchers he's a second antagonist
and is voiced by a familiar name I
played baldus Gate 3 like two years ago
at a preview event isn't that crazy
[Music]
to defend the citizens of Baldur's Gate
from enemies within and without
you are soon to witness the people who
was gate granting me complete power over
there I love him
a new age is upon us
gods have mercy on those who would stand
in our way a Mad Dog understands the
yank of the leash from the hand of its
Master but it cannot be an equal you can
be my equal there's an old wisdom a
brittle Alliance can never be mended it
can only break I want to lead this city
to Glory they're trying to make him hot
friends allies to my side
let us offer in a new dawn this city is
mine
I'm not ready to go City's very
impressive the combat was really cool a
lot of really cool puzzles wanna quit it
I mean that was really just an actor
reveal huh
getting close getting close
under control
oh I answered too
gortash
laughs
Baldur's Gate three is on tracks Fenn
tells me still for the end of August and
we can't wait to check that out all
right this fall Marvel games and
Insomniac are set to bring Spider-Man 2
exclusively to PlayStation 5. sounds
like you guys are a little hyped so to
tell us more is Brian into hard games
I know you guys are deep in development
first of all looks like we have some uh
fancy art behind us this is this the Box
this is the boxer you know isn't it here
it is I mean
has two on the box for a reason because
this game features two Spider-Mans so
we're really excited about it
miles uh we're so excited about this um
you know experience the gameplay like
blew my mind so it looks so [__] cool
great Gameplay at the PlayStation
showcase but I want to talk about the
two
villains I think in the game there may
be more there are more there are more
out there two main ones but uh we have
some new art to show of uh we have six
Craven we got the reveal at the
PlayStation event so tell us a bit about
uh him and how he's Craven's very
different from any character we've done
he's not you know he's not powered by
magic or you know Tech he's just the
best hunter in the world that he's
coming to New York for his greatest hunt
and what's better than all of the Marvel
characters that live in New York City so
Peter miles and others he's on the hunt
and others and others but and Venom also
obviously uh you know symbiote is a part
of this whole story as we saw in the
gameplay oh there you go
good reaction to the art uh I'm glad
you're happy I don't know how much
you're gonna tell us about then is this
uh can you tell is this is an Osborne
Venom you can tell what's the origin of
Eddie Brock Venom or it is not Eddie
Brock okay it is not it is not Eddie
Brock okay
um our goal was to tell an original
story something you haven't seen in the
comics of the movies yet obviously wow
we love venom for a reason yeah all
those things you love about the
character are going to be there but how
the story plays out
who is Venom you have to play the game
and see how it goes yeah wow okay that's
there's a bit of a tease now obviously
the the Symbiote is a big part of the
gameplay and and one of the things like
we were all struck with the footage that
you showed at the PlayStation showcase
was uh you know how that is going to
really impact the gameplay when you're
playing as you know Peter so tell us a
bit about that and how you know the
gameplay is going to be dramatically
different yeah I mean I think you saw in
just the the raw power the strength I
did think it looked incredible Peter's
moves in that in that in that gameplay
reveal you know he's you know we call
him the acrobatic improviser him and
miles but you can tell there's a lot
more strengths
you saw both in the moves and that's so
awesome it's not just what happens in
Game plates what happens how the story
plays out interesting so how it affects
him as well yeah I mean you saw some of
that and there's much more of that
Journey when you play the game and I
know the the journey is also more
expansive you've got Queens Brooklyn so
even more of sort of yeah I mean the
city is pretty much doubled in size so
it's meant it's Manhattan Queens
Brooklyn and then being able to use the
web Wings to Traverse at speeds way
faster than they were before
um is really awesome hugely ambitious
game you guys have been building uh over
the past I could watch gameplay like
obviously until we get to play it looks
so good fall 20 23 and I think you know
we're like getting close to that are you
guys feeling confident that gonna make
it this fall
you know Jeff I know you like exclusives
yes
and I can promise you we are very
confident what we're going to tell you
right now oh at least yeah okay yeah
let's take a look
sweet looking forward to it October 20th
Spiderman
video games awesome well Brian thanks so
much a lot of work to do wrapping up the
game but we'll check it out in October
thanks Brian hell yeah
we got our dates all right now let's
take a look at Power World a multiplayer
open world survival crafting game where
you can befriend and collect mysterious
creatures called pow who can also fight
in other words kind of like Pokemon with
guns and then
we're gonna look at the land of the
morning a new expansion to Black Desert
online which recreates the mythical folk
tales from Korea's joseon Dynasty and
some huge bosses too
[Music]
I think we've also seen this before
I mean that is a Gyarados ass looking
thing
wow Electabuzz oh my God
they're 100 Evie like they're literally
just going for Pokemon
like how close can we get
[Music]
what
let's go
God
what dude
God of War are you kidding this so
all of them are you guys not worried
about getting sued
e
wow
I mean I'm sure they have a legal team
that was like make it different enough
but that
was [__] close
[Music]
foreign
I feel like every time I make a dumb
joke now I have to say that was a joke
because
when watching the Metal Gear Solid
remake reveal I said grounded clearly as
a joke
um
and people have accused me of not being
judging despite working for PlayStation
and clearly nailing the crowded we met
in the PlayStation and that they didn't
look the same
that looks sick whatever it is but also
an issue of looking a little oh okay
June 14th
our story is I thought that was further
away Hobbits a battle of snow some of
these are just starting to look a little
too similar I told it ourselves it needs
to be more of a focus to making games
got real different
across Middle Earth gelding for riches
Golem two
sequel to The Smash Hit Golem
I'm not gonna lie I'm into this
Golem to Gimli
no I'm kind of into it
come my fellow dwarves
granny together Lord of the Rings dwarf
simulator
turn to Moria that's cool
I [__] with it
it does look like Tower Defense I'm very
very interested in this okay you keep
selling me this and I'm I am here and I
want it
that's [__] awesome I bet you it's
like a thousand dollars though
second notes to everybody absolute
Banger Samsung gaming Hub I've also
tried and found it very expensive
[Music]
I actually tried it at uh summer game
Fest play days last year it's really
cool
all right now we're gonna look at an
exciting new mobile game from a
legendary franchise
if we must oh oh we must
so sexy
I don't really want to know sephiroth
though
dude Zack oh
my boy
I look
it's a mobile game and I don't [__] with
them really ever
but it looked good though
does this video get hot too I wonder
maybe that'll be what we get at the end
of the show
it's probably gonna be destranding
let's be real it's going to be
desperating too
David
from the Fantasy 7 ever crisis okay
we have also heard about the crisis
before
free registration for Final Fantasy VII
ever crisis has just started and users
will have the chance to participate in
upcoming closed beta he must get paid
for that now speaking of final thing
that I find frustrating about these is I
don't know which no no no no today
during summer game Fest doordash has
your back you can get a free burrito
what do you order from Taco Bell you
can't do that game fast plus get the
chance to win a final fantasy 16 prize
pack you can't do that in your game um
yeah we got you I just ethically feel
like the game we debuted last year at
TGA I feel like he should have to the
story
it's Wilds of North America like how is
this legal
life to the living death to the Dead
oh yeah I remember seeing this
me
they should rename themselves don't time
we bring closure to those who don't
back red
I want revenge don't look so different
no the whole show is not mad
which is why it's confusing
they are not all ads some he gets paid
to put in some heels
right so they're not all ads
and if they were he would have to
disclose that regularly right yes
you do have to disclose that rates
Port-A-Potty as somebody who does that
you do have to disclose them
maybe he's got different times
red
everything
it is so nuts how different this is to
the other don't know game that's coming
out right now
crazy I would love to try it
again another game that I feel like is
looking a little bit similar we're
getting a lot of similar looking games
right now I feel like kova just happened
impact on everybody
foreign
[Music]
someone okay
I think he's so hot
maybe it isn't it like obviously it's
Yakuza but I mean like I expected like
it could it be in the remake no
just so many Yakuza games you know what
I'm saying
God I love Yakuza so much it's such a
good franchise
foreign
[Music]
oh sorry that's right I like the dragon
now not Yakuza I forgot it's it's no
longer
what the [__] I would like to know more
they're such good games though dude
they're so good
I hope you have a productive day I don't
I could I could talk right now bro but I
don't feel like there are many
franchises that pull off the time
adjusting morning wake up extremely
serious and Extremely Goofy without
anything being printed or I'm putting or
whatever as well
is this
it's a protocol
definitely a lake here Tim
how long has it been now
three years
two months and 17 days it's a cool
trailer it's very cinematic
also of operation are they running down
here no fancy
they shouldn't be here
someone there
this doesn't make sense
someone else down here he's also a
breathy
are you there
new IP
I really like that trailer
very moon it's a beautiful new game
under the waves and today incidentally
is World ocean day fun fact all right
thank you appreciate that Call of Duty
well there's a new Call of Duty coming
this fall along with Warzone Mobile
today we're going to give you the first
ever look at season four of Modern
Warfare 2 war zone launching next week
here's your first look at vondel a new
horizontal location with points of
interest including medieval castle a
soccer stadium and an abandoned Zoo yep
it's all happening check it out here you
go all right I'm not a world Zone player
it's also crazy the amount of people in
um the stream chat who are like begging
for the Fortnight like just constantly
I guess they still underestimate how
popular fortnite is
we want the city
looks good
looks good I guess
we started playing fortnite we're
probably married with kids now at this
point
when did it come out it came out while I
was still working at IGN
I don't think it's long enough for that
okay Battlefield
go
season four next week today is a big day
for video games with also a huge day for
Porsha the iconic German automaker
turned 75 years old today okay we
celebrate their contributions in the
automotive and gaming space and we've
all raced a 911 in some point at a game
Xbox has teamed up with Porsha for a
limited edition run of 75 consoles
inspired by six famous Porsche race cars
I'm thrilled to debut the first design
here today inspired by the Porsche 960.
is this it is this the thing I was
asking about the stream running of the
24th we're finally getting new Xbox
series X colors
about [__] time
also I do love the Porsche Island Club
[Music]
can I see them all
that's cool
what where did that come from
the Porsche Xbox series X these custom
consoles are not for sale but you can
enter for a chance to win one right now
at Porsche Xbox sweepstakes.com make
sure to stay tuned or is it social
channels for additional opportunities to
get your hands on these special consoles
all right next
Phoenix labs are building the next great
entry into the Cozy Farm Sim John we all
like I could get a lot of fun things
like animals stardew Valley previously
announced for Nintendo switch there's
now some exciting news for PC players
too let's take a look at Faith Farm
like was the whole thing just direct
this morning I think it was it's been
treating me well uh I started working
though so quickly
before I know it
it's been a breath of fresh air
[Music]
found a way to get cozy and settle and I
do love Animal Crossing
which is not really my kind of thing but
there's something more I've been itching
to explore I'm not a stardew valley
person either I wish I was
Realms where magic comes to meet us I
tried more than once I just couldn't get
it we're prepared we
AK to anything
so what do you say
there's so much yet to discover are you
ready
we promise variety there it is Faith
Farm and Mortal Kombat in the same show
now please welcome Ben bro see the
creatures had guns enthusiasts at second
dinner the developers behind the popular
collectible card game Marvel snap what's
up man
we've never played it I had so many
friends who's so into it fire last time
I saw you was at the game awards when
you won uh best mobile game uh seems
like you've been very busy we're excited
about the spider-verse content you've
been doing Lots going on over there
right yeah it's been uh it's been
exciting we've been doing a bunch of new
features some of the wildest cards we've
ever made and uh the man is very excited
I love it some new game modes yeah
is that is that a Segway Ben certainly
yeah I'm excited to announce Marvel
snaps biggest update ever uh we have a
new game mode
uh in some exciting new rewards but you
don't have to wait till next week if you
haven't tried model snap go down there
right now on your mobile device or early
access on Steam all right I love the
enthusiasm Ben yeah I feel like we are
getting a little bit about a low in the
middle of the show here all right well
we heard you brought uh something fun
with you for us to watch right y'all
might love model snap and listens
uh but some people and maybe you've had
this experience Jeff uh some people lose
yeah fair and I like to think it's
because they suck no offense Jeff
but sometimes yes sometimes it's because
they might just be a little bit unlucky
cue the tape
oh okay well
that was uh okay I don't have an ideal
hand of cards here but that's fine I'll
see what I draw the show
anyway let's reveal the first location
each player destroys their deck okay I
guess I will work with what I have I'll
play Medusa on location number two she
gets plus two power and let's see the
next location he's so [__] over
Dangerfield as a 25 chance of destroying
your cow okay well I mean 25 isn't that
bad and it's gone okay well I have some
powerful cards in my hand so I can just
wait these are really really really good
players cannot top four you're just
talking the other thing about how
perfect his Ragnarok costume was he's so
good also if you don't play a card this
turn you have zero friends
hmm
very good idea I hope you go paid a
bunch for that he rolls
still the cops he doesn't have podcasts
I was on it maybe a couple months ago
the original
s on his Channel
friends history of fortnite Wilds I
always call him
maybe this summer compare top credit
cards side by side with nerd wallet and
start maximizing your cash back rewards
on everything from Wi-Fi to headsets
Legends rise a new cross platform 35
game for mobile and PC a fantasy Squad
RPG Adventure that is available to
pre-register today
foreign
how long we've been going for an hour
and a half okay
there's a bit of a lull in the middle
here I think everything
save your kind
[Applause]
[Music]
dude he's hot
author could get it
you mean to tell me authors are baddie
okay
[Music]
yeah I figured it was not actual
gameplay
[Music]
what does it look like
also about it a game full of Baddies
King Arthur Legends rise pre-register
now
but what is gameplay but what gameplay
look like
but who was gameplay
wayfinders
do you remember the fall
the Gloom descended on skylight
to protect the beacon
terrible price
blood one two
and the world was broken can you believe
it
real new art style
turn to us this might be another game
this world needs Champions
no maybe not
oh
what battle choices
we've maybe also heard of wayfinder
before
I'm not super into the the look of that
but that's okay
doesn't all have to be to me
[Music]
fortnite no
wait what
okay it's a super cut I was like is
fortnite doing all of these different
art styles what the [__] it's a montage
of multiple games
sure
oh that's cool
unreal editor for fortnite does that
mean you don't stand a chance
custom maps
that's really cool
project under construction
what do you say guys one more game
good morning scavenger no one can get
away with that yeah your surroundings to
retrieve and recycle anything that could
be a value discover because I don't
think Gamers say what do you say guys
one more game we say ah yeah I could do
one more then I gotta go to bed
that's me every night Diablo 4 right now
Captain's Log
our date four three one five two point
four
our Fleet is cautiously entering hostile
territory
and the crew is standing by
yeah I said it nice at it
your shifts
and culture pretty bad vibes here that's
okay
sieve
okay Star Trek makes a lot more sense
than spaces
still in that Lull in the middle Jeff
not not super hot the last uh
30. receive my lifeless Banger let this
power flow through you and fight again
alongside your past selves
I'm here again
otherwise I begin again but with another
me to fight with it's a regular
uh Hades type if you will we should
start calling them Hades likes
I had these lightning I hate he's like
nobody's even played Rogue multiple
places at once
I will become Legion and Crush these
demons
looks cool
onwards I can feel that there are more
that's one of those ones where like
I'll wait for friends who are reviewers
to play it and I think they Rave about
it independent game all right next up is
a brand new IP from ascendant Studios a
single player also very terrible person
magic shooter called Immortals of avium
it's fast and fluid it's an FPS in a
fantasy setting kind of like doomed with
magic it also has a great cat cast led
by Darren Barnett as the main character
Jack and he joins us now hey Darren hey
guys people like wondering and awkwardly
is so funny
[Music]
value spectacular gameplay uh tell us
about the guy you play You're the main
character Jack right yes I'm playing the
main character Jack as seen behind me
he's a battle mage that controls all
three forms of magic Triple Threat uh
he's Brash he's funny but he gets the
job done I don't know this guy uh it's
the gameplay
uh you know with all the Spells the
spell casting and the magic
um what can you tell us about the story
and sort of how this battle mage Jack uh
comes in he sort of becomes a battle
major battle mage is my favorite from
nothing he's uh I guess they call him
um but he uh yeah during a uh time of
intense trauma he summons the power to
control magic uh becomes part of the
Immortals which is like the elite Navy
SEAL Squad of this world and they are in
the middle of an Ever War fighting for
the control of magic okay uh you have a
great cast you Gina Torres in it lots of
amazing actors in this incredible really
high production value game that's coming
out this summer we don't have to wait
long for it um and I know you brought
something with you to share today which
is a gameplay sequence which one of the
most epic sort of parts of the game
right yeah um so this is a wild part of
the game this trailer I think we've seen
this game before the Immortals in myself
that's a good point like actually that
maybe they should be posting is the time
gameplay
in the ever war and it's taking place in
like one of the most badass levels of a
video game I've seen we're battling on
top of a 400 foot Mech in the middle of
the ocean as it moves around
um it's wild so let's take a look that
sounds great let's take a look at some
brand new gameplay from Immortals of
avian which comes out this summer for PC
PS5 and Xbox thanks Darren thank you
thank you
sandrax literally pushed us to the edge
everyone that can fight why do I
literally though
[Music]
and we're still losing
I just really feel like at the moment
video game trailers are having trouble
distinguishing themselves from one
another
way companies are using like five knots
woke up too much of the same data or
something that's saying make them look
like this I just feel like they're all
looking
similar but maybe it's just when we see
them in a two-hour chunk like this you
know
like I'm having more trouble remembering
if I've seen things at previous
conferences before because I feel like
we're getting more similar looking games
yeah this one was the one that looked
kind of like us when I told you
it's very clearly like Avengers inspired
right like
I actually think I underrated ghostwise
thank you
I think that um
because I wanted it to be scary so bad
when I played it I thought it was just
okay
and I think if you remove the
expectation of horror from that game
it's actually pretty sick just in like a
unique way
you can see Metal Gear Solid 3 remake of
one of Jeff's shows I don't know about
yet
[Music]
Maybe
I'm also just not a big fan personally
of the that looks really cool nice
animation beautiful lighting here too
um
of of
magic games that are actually just bus
to shoot us
like full spoken I guess third person
shooter but it's still a shooter uh just
because it's coming out of your hands
doesn't make it less of a gun you know
scenery is really pretty
and it didn't
I wasn't bad
fight this war as one of you
can end the ever
the pentacide has gifted you with the
ability just not feeling this way
manifest all three colors
could again be one of those ones and
maybe I just need to play it oh that's
cool
we're only going to win this one
together also cool
yeah
it doesn't look inherently bad just
maybe not so much amazing raw gameplay
today and that game looks incredible
coming out this summer from ascendant
and EA now one game that constantly
reinvents itself
Chapter Four Season three Wilds launches
and today summer game Fest is debuting
the cinematic trailer to preview the
season the center of the island they do
make good cinematic trailers hidden
jungle with ancient secrets to discover
and of course there's a whole new battle
pass lineup where you can Unleash the
Power yes of Cybertron here we go
you already know I'm not really a
fortnight person
play it occasionally it is fun
Jeff's eyes are dead I do sometimes
wonder if he's had Botox because like if
you've had Botox people have had Botox
right they're bullets don't move like
they can't do that right like
so this is sort of like at all times
just not moving their eyebrows
yeah they can't emote yeah it's very
funny in movies
I don't see like act as an exorcist
who'd call it like brown probably so
funny
okay
people accuse me of having go talks
sometimes and I'm like have you seen how
expressive I am
how would that work
but I think they just do that when they
like don't really understand what photos
is what does
[Music]
like I get accused of having lit filler
every time I wear lipstick or um
the fighter every time
sorry I just talked over that whole
thing I really I'm really sorry anybody
who's here for fortnite it's just not
really my thing sometimes they do have
cool cinematic trailers I was expecting
them a story everyone though I apologize
tomorrow
finally guys
it's time to get to our grand finale
please don't cancel me and it is a deep
honor for me to present this game what
you're about to see is a world premiere
trailer it gives us a new look at an
expansive world we can't wait to explore
again
this game comes from a studio that
surprised the world and redefined the
RPG genre with its iconic characters and
Rich storytelling I want to thank them
for this trailer for one of Gaming's
most anticipated upcoming releases
the rumors Fable we're true I don't know
what room is I haven't seen any
we are still here at the scene of this
terrible disaster oh let's go oh let's
go through sector zero one and two oh my
god
um it's the wreckage of the expressway
search operations
Teddy's okay
somebody save the titties
oh my God oh my God oh my God okay okay
okay
I have Goosebumps everybody shut up
everybody shut up
you look that way
that way barely hanging
hanging I was wondering
what's Cloud been doing these past five
years where's he been and you're asking
me this it's five years between them
this is gonna sound crazy but
as far as I know it was never in me
behind five years ago
live stream
it is the very I love what they're doing
with this I think it's so cool the blood
coursing through its planetary veins
according to Hojo they're connected to
sephiroth
Shadows of the man I believe you called
them like are we going to see Zach
sephiroth was in midgar we fought him
whatever happened he's alive but why
come back now
[Music]
after five years doing who knows what
a run rate's cool
ster eyes on the Turks latest and
greatest Elena she may be new but
to turn
[Music]
cool
dude it looks so pretty
I just want to see more story stuff
though like I'm like but but but with
all of the questions which I imagine
will be answered in the game and
actually be terrible if they announce
them in this trailer that would actually
be a huge [__] bummer
foreign
[Music]
they say she's a monster
she can peer inside you
that she can become those you hate those
you fear
those you love I love him so much dude I
love him sorry yeah
you murdered my dad you burned my
Village
oh
do you know that I killed her
so who is she
[Applause]
damn
they kept that
pretty tight I was expecting more
reveals 67 rebirth coming early 2024
PlayStation 5 tomorrow Sun thank you so
much all right oh my God it's gonna do
it for summer game Fest our live
showcase but that is not the end of
summer game Fest stay tuned this weekend
for updates on Monday did it say two
discs
Hands-On event for media here in Los
Angeles including oh I love that 2077
fans of Liberty as well as the Xbox and
Bethesda showcase yeah excited I'll be
streaming the Xbox I am a bit and double
fine which celebrates the independent
game culture with a number of new game
reveals over the next okay I sadly can't
watch day of the day I'll see you this
summer later this summer on August 22nd
I gotta get back to work tonight live in
Germany and again in December when we
come together here in Los Angeles to
celebrate 10 years of the game awards
thanks for watching everyone we'll see
you soon it was fun that was definitely
um
like I said A Lull in the middle some
cool stuff I think Alan Wake 2 looks
really good very excited to see it this
weekend surprisingly no cyberpunk
um
I had a good time it wasn't it wasn't
amazing
[Music]
we liked it we had a fun we had a fun
time also surprised about no DS but I
guess we'll probably get it in December
I wonder how difficult that is would you
have to like decide
where
to put certain things
the Liza P demo I will definitely be
playing today you'll 100 I'll put that
up on YouTube
um so we will next be live foa
I'm not gonna do the wholesome direct
it's Sunday morning for Xbox Bethesda so
I will stream that too uh thank you for
hanging out with me today
I appreciate you
this was fun
um I'll put Liza P demo gameplay up when
I get a chance probably off to work
today